as movies become more and more reliant
on computer effects the entire landscape
of filmmaking is changing and sometimes
there aren't any landscapes at all
because it's all done in front of a
green screen
the end result movie sets look
completely ridiculous here's a
behind-the-scenes look at what some of
your favorite movies look like before
the special effects team went to work
the Planet of the Apes effects studio
wet a digital changed the game when they
helped reboot Planet of the Apes with a
new trilogy of prequels beginning with
2011's rise of the Planet of the Apes
producer Dylan Clark had a special
amount of praise for Andy Serkis
the industry's top performance capture
artist shown as protagonist Caesar
redefining screen acting in the digital
age Andy Serkis
is unlike any other actor he can inhabit
characters that don't speak can demote
in ways that you don't really see often
Fox campaign for circuits to get an
Oscar nomination but the call from the
Academy never came much to the actors
frustration after the release of 2017 s
War of the Planet of the Apes circus
told independent the awarding bodies
should not discriminate about this being
different the visual effects render the
character just like putting on makeup
except here it happens after the fact
it's digital makeup if you will Harry
Potter
bringing JK Rowling's Wizarding World to
life was only ever going to be possible
with the help of CGI and the films made
increasingly good use of visual effects
with each installment while early CGI
hasn't aged well the quality of digital
imagery from Goblet of Fire onward still
holds up the VFX team had to up their
game for the fourth film in the series
as it marked the return of Lord
Voldemort Paul Franklin the VFX
supervisor for order of the Phoenix and
half-blood Prince revealed that creating
Voldemort snows was a mammoth task
Franklin told Radio Times there's this
idea that we put the shots through the
computer and it just vanished off his
face his nose had to be painstakingly
edited out frame by frame over the whole
film and then the snake slits had to be
added and tracked very carefully using
dots put on his face for reference
that's a lot of work for a couple no
slits but Voldemort just wouldn't have
been the same without them
melanda masala Bandai nothing's too good
for James Ponte Life of Pi filming this
tale of a boy stranded at sea with a
Bengal tiger came with a number of
obstacles but the biggest one wasn't the
tiger it was the water director Angley
explained I knew that to make it work
with 3d water had to become a character
itself I've never seen realistic water
scenes in movies because water hits one
side of a tank wall and bounces back
like it would in a bathtub but we needed
to make it work that's not to say the
tiger was easy to create either scenes
in which PI interacts with the deadly
animal we're done using a crude puppet
the rest of it had to come from CGI Game
of Thrones the season finales on Game of
Thrones always have a cinematic quality
thanks in part to the digital wizardry
of pixel mondo green-screen use is kept
to a minimum where possible but bringing
the creatures of George RR Martin's
world into the mix requires some
top-notch CGI pixel mandos VFX
supervisor spin Martin told The
Washington Post that one of their
biggest achievements has been making
Daenerys dragons blend seamlessly with
the world around them but all that magic
doesn't happen until the dragon scenes
have been shot so how does Emilia Clarke
connect with her fire-breathing babies
Green puppets
the actress told Huffington Post they
have these amazing life scale models
that we use for camera rehearsals for
the sake of the CGI people and I got
very attached to them fundamentally
they're dolls I suppose but it was nice
to have something physical that I could
really picture in my mind Alice in
Wonderland Tim Burton was creating
stunning visual effects long before
relying heavily on CGI using a
combination of practical techniques to
bring his vision to the screen the
former Disney artists use stop-motion
animation
miniatures and puppetry to great effect
in his earlier works though when the
opportunity to direct his own version of
Alice in Wonderland came along he soon
realized that he couldn't do it without
leaning heavily on digital wizardry this
means that all the stars of the movie
had to do the bulk of their acting in
front of green screens
according to visual effects supervisor
Ken Ralston it was a challenge for the
whole team the green-screen color after
long periods of time seems to create a
certain aggravation and irritation after
staring at it for a long period it is
effective for compositing but visually
and psychologically exhausting
to be surrounded by it for extended
periods of time Beauty and the Beast
when Disney first announced their
intention to remake a number of their
beloved Animated Classics and
live-action format the title that raised
the most eyebrows was Beauty and the
Beast a film in which the majority of
the supporting characters are animated
household objects was always going to
rely on CGI though director Bill Condon
has never liked digital effects and
actively avoided using them wherever
possible
he told indieWIRE it was important to
make everything that could be real real
I'm not a big fan of CG movies
the idea is to feel grounded in a world
and not be distracted by things that
felt like additions unfortunately for
the actor portraying the beast Dan
Stevens it was motion capture all the
way plus some stilts to get him to the
right height it wasn't easy
on stilts Stephen spoke to both Andy
Serkis and Mark Ruffalo about their
experiences in motion capture roles and
their feedback left him sweating he
added I think I was mildly terrified but
that's really generally what drives a
lot of my decisions these days is
calibrating the right amount of terror
nothing like a Disney movie to get that
fear meter upright The Dark Knight
Christopher Nolan is notorious for using
real-life effects as much as possible
and most of the big effects in the Dark
Knight were done on camera the only
visual effect involved in that scene was
true removed the RAM that they had built
inside the truck but the Dark Knight
still offered some unique CG challenges
especially since it was the first film
to shoot scenes with IMAX cameras as
opposed to using 35-millimeter and
converting and post visual effects
supervisor Nick Davis spoke to studio
daily about his experience on the Batman
flick saying it was important for the
visual effects to look as though they
were shot on set Nolan didn't want the
film to take on a gimmicky visual
effects look taking this route meant
that Nolan's first sequel to 2005's
Batman Begins was a difficult movie to
finish as the visual effects had to be
rendered in a higher resolution than
ever before when it came to creating the
look for Harvey two-face dent
Nolan wanted to remove layers not add
them the VFX team had to digitally
remove the skin two phases exposed
eyeball had to be painstakingly animated
by hand as were the subtle changes in
muscle tension gravity the biggest
challenge Alfonso Cuaron faced making
his space epic gravity was achieving a
realistic lack of gravity on screen
pulling it off involved an intricate
mixture of practical and digital effects
that there are flesh and there are
mistakes as a weapon
no mistakes it's all creative the
director talked to space about the
challenges and getting the effects to
look realistic saying it took a lot of
Education for the animators to fully
grasp that the usual laws of cause and
effect don't apply in outer space there
is no up there is no down co-stars
Sandra Bullock and George Clooney were
advised of their movements by real
astronauts before being hooked up to a
series of rigs created by Academy
award-winning visual effects artist Neil
corbelled it turns out that Bullock not
only had to put up with being suspended
from wires most of the day there were
electric shocks to contend with - core
bald explained there was a charge in
there like the static you feel
underneath an electricity substation if
you walked out and touched someone you'd
get this massive shock it may not have
been easy work for the actors but it
worked out pretty well for corbelled who
won his second Oscar for gravity the
matrix arguably one of the most
influential films of all time the matrix
truly changed the landscape of action
movies with its memorable fight
sequences becoming a benchmark for stunt
coordinators and VFX artists alike the
term bullet time was coined for the epic
slow-motion shots that the movie
employed on the regular which were
created by visual effects guru John
Gaeta Gaeta told the New York Times the
directors wanted to emulate the
stylization found in Japanese animation
when we created whether fire and smoke
we wanted it to move not realistically
but impressionistic Lee raw footage
released as an extra on the DVD showed
how bullet time was achieved using an
intricate setup of perfectly positioned
cameras and masses of green-screen the
Lord of the Rings
whenever Peter Jackson's The Lord of the
Rings trilogy comes up the first thing
most people mention is Andy Serkis is
brilliant motion capture performance
though creating Gollum was just one of
many challenges what a face during the
movies practical solutions like
miniature models and forced perspective
were used in places but the bulk of the
visual effects were achieved digitally
even the interior of Bilbo Baggins his
hobbit hole was computer-generated for
some shots speaking to a wnd visual
effects supervisor Jim Rygel revealed
that Return of the King was his favorite
of the three movie
because of the monumental amount of work
he and his team put into the picture
he explained Return of the King has more
shots than 1 & 2 combined it's like 1450
it was mind boggling to figure out
logistically how to do them all it's
something you never think you could have
done and you did it like climbing Mount
Everest Pirates of the Caribbean Dead
Man's Chest Bill Nighy EES character
Davy Jones made his first appearance in
2006 his Dead Man's Chest although you
may not have recognized the actor under
all those digital tentacles well I was
once required to be a squid man in a
movie I was an octopus guy and I was
perfectly happy watching that because
what are you gonna say unless you don't
like my squid well then you know live
with it visual effects supervisor John
Knoll was able to develop a method that
allowed Nighy to be on set with his
fellow actors instead of filming
separately in front of a green screen
which in turn allowed him to interact
more believably and deliver a farm are
genuine performance Knoll describes a
process to ews aim on a soundstage with
25 technicians staring at bill and
nobody to play off of that quirkiness
would have all gotten ironed out
somebody would say that gesture is too
off or too odd he could have become a
real sort of committee effort my squid
was welled closed my squid was an
award-winning squid because the hundred
men and women who created my squid the
post-credits scene in pirates of
caribbean dead men tell no tales opened
the door for the return of supernatural
sea lord Davy Jones although now he had
no part in it in fact he had no idea his
award-winning squid was even in the
movie until a taxi driver told him about
it thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]